life has certainly been good for
chadwick boseman since he became the
king of Wakanda but fans of the Black
Panther star are suddenly worried for
his health those worries arose after
Bozeman took to Instagram to post a self
shot video and celebration of what would
have been Major League Baseball's Jackie
Robinson day with professional baseball
suspended indefinitely Bozeman who
portrayed Jackie Robinson in the 2013
biopic 42 chose to celebrate the day
anyway with a video post that was also
meant to commemorate the launch of
Operation 42 a collaboration between
Thomas Tull and FIGS who manufacture
surgical scrubs the noble collaboration
made a 4.2 million dollar donation to
supply medical gear to african-american
communities hardest hit by the pandemic
they're going to execute the
distribution of those scrubs of those
masks of those isolation gowns
to those hospitals that have been
impacted the most
rather than celebrating Jackie Robinson
day and operation 42 s huge donation
alongside the actor Bozeman's fans were
instead taken aback by his appearance in
the video
noting specifically his dramatic weight
loss the comments section on the video
quickly filled up with questions about
Bozeman's health the video itself has
since been removed from the main feet of
Bozeman's instagram page but it can
still be seen in the IG TV section of
his profile Bozeman is indeed not
looking like his usual self in the video
with sunken eyes prominent cheekbones
and a shaggy beard given the current
state of the world fears over Bozeman's
health are probably a bit more
heightened than usual the good news is
that Bozeman still seems very healthy in
the video and genuinely excited that
operation 42 has been such a success
however the fact that the video in
question has been unceremoniously
removed from the main portion of
Bozeman's Instagram feed is still a bit
worrisome that coupled with the radio
silence coming from the actor and his
management team is fueling the fires of
concern on all fronts looking at the
video one might be inclined to believe
Bozeman has probably begun a weight loss
regimen in preparation for a future role
that is after all a familiar enough
tactic for actors having been utilized
by a listers like Christian Bale Matthew
McConaughey Anne Hathaway and most
recently
Joaquin Phoenix in his oscar-winning
Joker turn still those actors
their reps have historically been quick
to announce the planned weight loss and
tend to do so literally the moment
pictures of the sometimes dangerously
thin performers begin to surface with no
announcement coming from Bozeman's camp
yet fans imaginations are left to run
wild and we all know just how wild those
imaginations can be while we await news
as to what's really going on with
chadwick boseman shocking weight loss we
can offer a little insight into what
role he might have lost wait for a peek
at the actors IMDB page will show you
that he has a handful of projects in the
works with Marvel's blacc panther2
obviously being the standout but given
the physical nature of Bozeman's MCU
work it's highly unlikely he'd go
through such a dramatic transformation
for the sequel there are however a
couple of projects in Bozeman's future
that could explain the weight loss he's
set to star in a sci-fi series entitled
the black child as well as a biopic
entitled Yosuke which finds the actor
playing a 16th century slave warrior who
went on to become the only known samurai
of African origin either of those roles
could necessitate weight loss and a
gaunt physique while many are concerned
over Bozeman's current appearance
starkly different from the muscle-bound
physique there used to him sporting on
the screen in the MCU there are some who
have argued that when he isn't bulking
up for a movie role the actor has always
been thin I wanted to go old-school for
my first day yeah bet the elders loved
that notably filmmaker and journalist
Zilla Valentine headed to Twitter with
the video of him interviewing postman in
2017 during a junket for Marshall a
biopic in which the star played the
first black US Supreme Court Justice
Thurgood Marshall in the caption of the
video Valentine wrote that Bozeman is
quote just as skinny dude he continued
back in 2017 when I interviewed him for
Marshall we joked about our dinner at
Red Rooster and how he is now vegan he
has been this slim activist April rain
also noted in a tweet that Bozeman is
simply a slender guy and that there
isn't cause for concern here she said
having had the privilege of being in the
same room with chadwick boseman a few
times my experience is that he's
naturally thin perhaps many of the roles
you remember him for require him to bulk
up but on the regular he's fine y'all
she also cheekily added that bowsman is
an attractive guy no matter what at this
point any and every opinion as to what
or may not have led to chadwick boseman
x' weight loss is pure conjecture check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
you